Alice Johnson joins us from Memphis
along with her daughter Katina scales
good morning to both of you I know this
was your first night morning in 21 years
how are you doing this morning I'm doing
great I woke up without a bottle bit
over my head that's right in Katina what
is it like having your mother home oh
the excitement and the happiness and
knowing that she's sitting right here
next to me and there's no Garth anywhere
that's wonderful
Alice you noticed that there was no bunk
bed over you what else have you noticed
since you've been out the city has
changed a lot I kept asking where am I
there's so many new buildings and I've
noticed that I've noticed people on the
phone a lot Alice what what's your plan
the first day of freedom we know you're
doing some television of course what are
you gonna do with your time what are you
gonna do with your family
we are just connecting last night we had
such a huge reunion and today is face to
family and friends today tell us what it
was like to get that phone call from Kim
kardashian-west that lets you know that
you'd be getting out it was the most
incredible day of my life the most
incredible amazing overwhelming day
moment of my life when Kim told me that
I could go home I started screaming and
jumping up and I know people that were
looking in the window probably thought I
was having some kind of fit what do you
want to say to her I want to tell my
world angel that I thank you for never
giving up that you did it you never gave
up on me you fought and you fought until
I was free and that was one thing that
she told me is that she would not give
up on me I just like to thank her and
hug her
Alice in the video that first caught Kim
kardashian-west attention you said the
real miss Alice is a woman who has made
a mistake tell us how you came to that
conclusion and and how you turned your
life around when you were in prison for
me I know that this is something that I
can't even imagine that I did what I did
in the beginning but I turned my life
all the way around in prison and decided
that I am NOT going to just do time or
let time do me I'm going to make the
most of this opportunity and I'm going
to be of service to others because
really that's what life is about life is
more than just living for yourself and
it was a big wake-up call for me too to
see to just be around the women that I
was around my perception of prison was
totally different and Alice will you if
you had a chance to talk to the
president what would you tell him I
would tell President Trump thank you so
much that I am going to be that one that
is going to make you so proud and I hope
that my life will encourage him to do
this for others too well I know that
there are more than 2,000 nonviolent
drug offenders that are still serving
life sentences are you going to spend
part of your life outside jail trying to
help them I have to yes I have that I
feel that I have that responsibility to
them to also reach back and help them
well Alice Johnson and Katina scales we
thank you so much for joining us this
morning we wish you the best thank you
for having us on it's remarkable to
think about what she did in prison
because she was a minister to so many
other women there and because of her
good behavior the warden allowed her to
do these video conferences or just how
she sort of became somewhat of a
celebrity in certain communities that
allowed her to get in front of President
Trump she's a playwright I'm sure she
will be continuing to penned some dramas
as she is out power of redemption